first of all Rook C7 Rook C7 is probably
made so you can't you can't even do that
so yeah no running and hiding here so so
we're once again entering a situation
where it would appear that Leon is one
precise calculation away from what will
be an absolutely overwhelming Advantage
I can't imagine that alir is intending
to play something like Queen E7 which is
the best move in the position but you
know you're you aspire to this you know
you're losing this one exactly looking
in
and now after B6 B5 there are drawing
chances again I give up no don't give up
not quite not yet it's called humans
playing yes right but I've played those
humans and they're really really good me
me they would be 10 out of 10 that's
life isn't it you know against you they
play like a like a beast yeah Queen
takes B6 and Away you go